qui dit que le vin correspond pas du
tout au moine parce que ça fait le cette
boisson le vin fait apostasier même les
sages une quoi qu'il arrive si dans
l'excès de 20 on peut rogner le Christ
etc enfin voilà ça convient pas du tout
au moine qui doivent être tempérant etc
mais voilà ça Benoît est fin connaisseur
de nature humaine il dit mais comme ce
serait trop difficile trop compliqué
voire impossible de priver l'homme de
cette boisson là mieux vaut limiter les
dégâts c'est la bière corona
lors de la finale du Top 14 toulousain
Rochelle le médecin que vous dites dit
bravo monsieur le Président alors que le
médecin qui n'a jamais fait ça une fois
dans sa vie me jette la première bière
Laurence Ferrari allez Olivier
et donc il fixe illumine par jour la
quantité de vin par frère alors
qu'est-ce qu'une émine
on sait pas du coup ça arrange beaucoup
de monde c'est un mystérieux gang des
rillettes comme le surnomme nos
confrères du monde ces dernières
semaines au moins trois distributeurs
ont été vandalisés en pleine nuit à
Solesmes Saint-Jean-de-la-Motte et Saint
Vincent du lourdware vitre fracassée à
coups de masse ou de pieds de biche non
pas pour voler l'argent de la machine
qui ne prend pas les pièces uniquement
les paiements par carte non les Vandales
ne s'en prennent qu'à la marchandise à
chaque fois ils ont dévalisé l'automate
et emporter tous les pots de rillettes
par dizaines
qui est de ni jusqu'à la société ni
jusqu'à l'hybriété voilà en gros ça a
été avant de ne plus avoir soif et là
vous êtes comment là qu'ils ont qu'on
pourra en boire une autre mais on va pas
le faire respecter la règle
tout simplement et la gendarmerie a
ouvert une enquête sur cette série de
vol mais pour l'instant le gang des
rillettes du Mans recherché est toujours
dans la nature le gang des rillettes
Dumas rechercher le papier de Guillaume
bien chef du service police justice de
RMC on chauffe bien on remue et on
retourne encore et encore et tu sais
comment on finit par le cuir
c'est écrit sur la carte l'amour en
cuisine
[Applaudissements]
donc là c'est compliqué pour moi des
sanglots dans la voie Zidane est un par
un fier il a inauguré hier la première
maison de France dédiée aux enfants en
fin de vie près de Marseille je suis
fier de pouvoir justement être le
parrain
de votre projet
[Musique]
qui sont des portables
et mon histoire ils vont tous me touche
lui qui a perdu son frère d'un cancer en
2019 n'a pas réussi à retenir ses larmes
un moment fort en émotions reposé par
l'association le point rose qui
accompagne les familles touchées par la
maladie
on est tous d'accord
et mes parents
j'ai perdu un frère donc mes parents
l'ont eu et je sais que c'est dur
avec dadju on précise que c'est votre
frère il y a de la jalousie il y a un
peu de compète à défaut de jalousie
entre frangins
beaucoup d'animosités beaucoup de
non c'est vrai pour de vrai la compète
il y en a à défaut de jalousie
tout ce que vous n'aimez
on avait fini par la Croix éternelle
libre malicieuse et doué écrivain
critique chroniqueuse Claude Sarraut
était devenu un des piliers des
émissions de Laurent Ruquier et des
Grosses Têtes la célèbre journaliste et
romancière nous a quitté celle qui était
par ailleurs membres de l'Association
pour le droit de mourir dans la dignité
c'était un naturellement à l'âge de 80
15 ans fêté tous ces anniversaires tous
ensemble
à New York Cuba pardon j'ai beaucoup de
mal parce que j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
qui reviennent et un danger mais cette
femme c'est une femme formidable on a
écrit j'ai écrit avec elle un livre qui
raconte toute sa vie elle avait
tellement de choses à raconter tellement
de choses à partager j'aurais envie de
rire parce que il y a quelques semaines
encore j'étais chez elle j'avais la voir
assez régulièrement et on riait beaucoup
à la télévision elle fait face aux
dirigeants communistes Georges Marchais
avec aplomb si vous aviez des théories
qui te plaisent tellement aux Français
des moyens de sortir de cette crise
qu'est-ce qui les empêcherait d'adhérer
aux parties qu'est-ce qui les
empêcherait de lire l'humanité que vous
n'êtes pas convaincant quand même ça a
été une femme très belle et ça a été une
femme très libre et notamment très libre
sexuellement amoureusement on rappelle
parce que ça n'est pas évident pour
cette génération là de le dire aussi
publiquement elle a eu un moment donné
deux hommes et peut-être même trois à la
fois en tout cas deux hommes clairement
et elle a su ça avec une joie de vivre
extraordinaire
non mais je suis très bien comme ça j'ai
pas envie de repasser les slips et les
slips vas-y les chemises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc
[Applaudissements]
regardez ce que je trouve
ça
c'est un grand classique rien n'échappe
à l'oeil de lynx et au sens aigu du
toucher de nos marchands il y avait bien
un trésor familial dans ce meuble en
plus de sa belle signature ces
trouvailles historiques vont-elles peser
dans la balance des enchères
[Musique]